hey guys so according to edge magazine
who just released a review of
blood-borne if you're one of the people
who complained that Dark Souls 2 was too
easy then you ought to blame for
blood-borne being so difficult they call
blood-borne a brutal riposte to the
playerbase that thinks it's seen it all
before
and from what I've played I think I have
to agree with them when you pick this up
on March 24th you can't just expect to
die that's something everybody expects
when they pick up a Souls game for the
first time no this game is going to
challenge the muscle memory that you've
learned for the past six years and it's
going to punish you if you play the same
way as you did in the last three souls
games you're going to feel out of your
depth and I expect that you're going to
have to adapt I also expect that this is
welcome news for most of you so here's
an example of something I guarantee
you'll do at least once you're going to
accidentally heal yourself when you go
to switch weapons that's because they've
changed to handing from triangle to l1
the bastards triangle is now you're
dedicated healing button through which
you'll accidentally and purposefully
consume blood valves and this action of
healing is fast just like every other
thing in blood-borne you dodge faster
the enemies attack faster where the
souls games are deliberate and
methodical blood-borne is frantic and
dynamic gone other days where you just
hang back and respond to your enemy in
blood-borne you need to attack first you
need to stagger your enemy and you need
to be too fast for them to respond so to
start with recent news you guys should
expect to be able to play with your
mates a lot more easily in blood-borne
because there's this new feature in
co-op called the watchword now the
watchword is essentially a password
that's 8 digits long that both you and
your friend set so that you can connect
more seamlessly with each others worlds
and so you're probably thinking oh hey
this new summoning mechanic it makes the
game so much easier right well don't
worry they found a way to balance it out
because whenever you summon somebody in
co-op it also summons their spell maiden
and she's not friendly when she appears
she'll ring her Bell and
she'll summon an invader into the world
so whenever you invite somebody into
your world to help you you're also
inviting invaders into your world to
kill you just to even the playing field
I like this change a lot and there are
even going to be areas where this Belle
maiden is present from the very
beginning forcing you to engage in PvP
so obviously invaders have been
confirmed - and apart from this invader
summoning mechanic it seems like they
work much the same as in the souls games
but once they invade they kill you and
they get rewarded the invader in this
picture is wielding a rapier that folds
out into a pistol and on that topic
we've seen a total of nine transformable
weapons thus far though someone can
correct me if I'm wrong there's that
sore which you all know there's a sword
that acts as the arm of the hammer a
long sword that sheaths into a great
sword the rapier gun I just mentioned
there's also a whip that stacks up into
a cane
there's the handheld scythe that
attaches to a longer folding blade
there's the long axe that shortens into
itself
there's the thin sword that snaps in
half for dual wielding and we have this
one image of a character that's holding
a sort of cleaver type weapon that
clearly also doubles as a kind of
mechanical gun such a cool selection of
weapons and when you start the game it
actually gives you three of these
transformable weapons to choose between
it reminded me of choosing a Pokemon
there's the so clever
there's the axe and there's the cane
that turns into a whip and you also get
to choose between two guns the
blunderbuss which is like a shotgun or
the pistol personally I don't really
mind what I start with because I am
gunning for whatever build lets me use
that scythe I call dibs on that one
simply due to the burden of design I
feel like there's going to be less
weapons in the game but there's so much
depth to each weapon that whatever you
use really defines your character and
how you play and most of you will be
playing more aggressively let me tell
you with the new regain mechanic you get
health back when you attack right after
getting
it and this mechanic changes so much I
think that this mechanic exists in
tandem with you actually taking more
damage in blood-borne than any other
Souls game as enemies attack really
[ __ ] fast in this game so players who
play more cautiously will find
themselves getting severely punished
it's not just about avoiding attacks in
this game it's also about how you deal
with getting hit for example if you just
like it every time you take damage and
run back and heal you're gonna run out
of those healing potions you kind of
need to replenish some of your health
whenever you take damage just to
minimize the impact that has and running
out of potions is a thing in this game
because as far as we know you can only
get more blood vials by finding them in
the world so expect to be farming these
a fair bit if you use them too often so
if you get hit until you fall down and
you die well there's this new element to
the death mechanic enemies who kill you
appear to absorb your souls or in this
game blood echoes whether this makes
them stronger we don't know but it is a
cool change the enemy who took your
blood echoes will have glowing eyes and
an aura meaning that you actually have
to overcome the enemy that bested you
meaning that you have to do better than
the last time where you died it's
actually a mechanic that we've seen
appropriated by a couple of souls like
titles like Lords of the Fallen and salt
and sanctuary it works perfectly because
it halts your ability to just run back
to where you died you actually have to
fight back
to where you died
so where do you spend these echoes well
there seems to be a new hub area called
the hunters dream and this area seems to
function just like the Nexus did in
Demon's Souls featuring from what I
count to be eleven different headstones
that warp you to different parts of the
world and I say that it is separate from
the rest of the games world because a
narrator refers to warping as returning
to reality therefore I think it's pretty
safe to say that the dream is separate a
place that hunters go to rest and
recuperate before adventuring out into
the relevant parts of the world and I'd
also say that the areas that we walk to
are part of one interconnected city but
that warping gives you a shortcut to a
different Check Point
within the city I think that this is the
most logical thing to conclude based on
the information we have and within the
hub a few other things have been spotted
there's a fireplace where you can
upgrade your weapon with blood stones
there's a living doll with the same
voice as the maiden in black from demon
souls who I would guess has the same
purpose of leveling you up she's asked
the question what do you desire after
all so that kind of speaks for itself to
me let's finish on the story this
trailer is one of the only ones that
isn't exclusive actually managed to get
a source file from Sony so what is
yharnam the city were dropped into
Jahna missed the home of blood
ministration you need only unravel its
mystery but where's an outsider like
yourself to begin easy with a bit of
yharnam blood of your own this is La
Sofia who appears in the opening
cinematic of the game he gives us our
vague objective kind of like ring the
bell of awakening was in Dark Souls we
have to unravel the mystery of yharnam
with the blood of this city to help us
but how does blood help us the man that
makes us human makes us more than human
makes us human no more
I believe this statement describes the
sequence of events the blood we have
makes us human and then we are more than
human we become increasingly based like
with increased ability perhaps
supernatural strength and then we are
human no more and the transformation to
becoming a beast is complete perhaps
this is the transformation that gripped
all of Yanam and perhaps we willingly
become part of this transformation in
the opening sequence infecting ourselves
with blood that makes us stronger to
finish I'd also like to talk about what
you can expect from this channel going
into blood-borne I've spent a long time
thinking about all the different series
ideas I could do and thinking about what
I've done badly and Dark Souls 2 and
what I could do better and I think I'm
starting blood-borne really strong with
Dark Souls 2 I went in anticipating all
these amazing characters in this deep
law and it wasn't really like that and I
was forced to adapt on the spot with 10
things and story mode and I had to
abandon my walkthrough series because
the game was so damn easy things like
that really threw me off but with
blood-borne I'm really confident based
on what I've played that these series
will stick one of them is focused around
community involvement another one
focused around how hard the game is
shaping up to be and I also have one
series that's going to help us delve
into the lore of an entirely different
universe
the day before blood-borne releases I
think I'm going to announce all the
series's that are coming so you guys can
get used to the idea of what I'm going
to be putting out and I think I will
tell you the day before release rather
than now because some people have been
known to copy the structure of the
channel so I think I'll keep it under
wraps and let you guys know a little bit
later but I also have to ask is there
anyone in the audience who isn't
actually getting blood-borne I realized
that there are going to be those people
not everyone can afford a ps4 it's just
not justifiable to some people who have
an Xbox or a PC and I get that
obviously I'd love you all to be
involved in this but for those of you
who can't play the game I hope you still
enjoy watching my content on it because
it's going to be the heart of this
channel for the next few months that
said I do have some Souls content
planned later this year so look out for
that and thanks for sticking with the
channel if you don't play blood-borne
but regardless I'll see you guys all
again soon Cheers and thanks so much for
watching bye
[Music]